you're my uncle I love you so much
really what are you doing in my car it's
a long story
not today Bianca I mean I watch both
episodes of the comedy special so funny
I think people are who are huge fans of
you are in for a treat especially if
they don't get to you know see your act
on the road so for people who are
unaware how would you explain this
comedy event well first of all thank you
for the compliment
it was a lot of fun to get to do the
creators of drag race world of wonder
basically were excited about this idea
and I loved working with them obviously
when I did RuPaul's Drag Race so here
was this chance for me to get to do
something that was a little more
mainstream you know because it for years
i'd worked in clubs and traveling with
my stand-up show which was not today
Satan was my show and they had an idea
for this where it's my life now that I'm
transplanted here in Los Angeles
Hollywood in Hollywood the place were
you supposed to be and so I come to
Hollywood with big dreams and hopes and
everything kind of goes wrong so we
documented every get to witness a lot of
the LA life here you know not all people
who are chasing their dreams you land in
LA and all of a sudden have this comedy
special so you kind of made it already
did you go we'll see we'll see everybody
what actually airs of course one of the
best things about this is that there's a
lot of grey celeb cameos and yeah who
was your favorite to work with well the
one that shocked me the most was Tori
Spelling I was most shocked by her she's
a hoot very very funny great city camera
can laugh about herself but what's the
key to your success do you have a rich
daddy who produces lots of TV shows uh
no but I did an elderly gentleman that I
call daddy
did he have series on the airs at the
path I need to go and she was great to
work with in that moment I mean
basically she's thrown in a car with me
and magic happens let me give you the
lowdown on the Hollywood fads cuz they
are all bull I've done gluten on gluten
vegan paleo Pilates yoga anal bleaching
vaginal steaming actually there is one
thing have you ever heard of the primal
scream the primal scream yeah
and I say it so it was pretty it was
pretty severe you also pay homage to a
lot of Hollywood icons you know there's
Sharon Stone Joan Rivers whose heels
were the best to step into actually the
Basic Instinct Sharon Stone thing was a
lot of fun because I hadn't seen the
movie in a while tella prints miss ray
what is that and I was surprised to see
how much of the nastiness actually made
it but it was quite exciting to get you
to you because I don't consider myself a
sexual person I'm more of an erotic
clown yeah I know you're shocked by that
yeah you're shocked what has been a
career highlight for you throughout this
whole process since drag race oh my god
um well just just to get to work
globally you know to get to go to
Australia and realize that there's
people that want to see you when you're
doing a 2,000 seat theater that's sold
out that's the part that I can't wrap my
brain around you know you were a
standout and drag race of course you won
looking back on that is there anything
you would have done differently no I'm
good with letting it go it's like a
relationship it was a great time I can't
change anything about it if I would have
changed one thing it could have changed
all of it but uh but it really was an
amazing experience to have at that point
in my life it was all in good fun oh
you're doing it for the comedy you know
I know we're in it and you know we're
doing this day to day so people start
losing their minds so it makes for
magical television what do you want to
do next like you know that everybody
likes to ask that question I don't know
you sure I don't rule anything 2017 what
do you want I'd always just did a
podcast with real rooms like what do you
want to do now I'm like I would do
anything but I recently said I'd like to
host the Oscars why not that's a long
boring a show they need to have somebody
in there to shake things up you know
who's doing that now who Jimmy Kimmel oh
he is announced today yeah oh honey
we're hoping to get on his show well
hoping I was gonna say it was it was a
gag enough first episode any advice for
Jimmy hosting the Oscars well no I mean
be funny try that be funny Jimmy we're
gonna do a little word association okay
give me a quick read on some of our
favorite Hollywood stars are you ready
auto help I know them all I'm really bad
about this okay Justin Bieber if I
wanted to sleep with a lesbian I'd grab
them Mariah Carey
oh stop singing now the reality show I
heard is like is a who you guys are
Network pals now oh yeah yeah I work on
it ha ha ha ha ha Kanye West oh I don't
think much about him he thinks too much
of himself so he doesn't really need me
to praise him at all but that's that's
an insane thing I mean now in this room
you got Kanye you know you've got Trump
anything is possible apparently the rock
is the highest-paid actor and Hollywood
and sex
a lot nuts what are we living it what a
year there's hope for me in 2017 hey
guys thanks for watching ET on youtube
for more great videos be sure to click
to subscribe